[Music]
good afternoon
to all the film independent members and
guests out there
in the virtual world out there on zoom
thanks for joining us
uh for this online virtual edition of
film independent presents my name is
cooper hopkins
i have worked at film independent for a
long time and i'm very excited
because today we have a very special q a
unlike really any we've
done before and i'm going to introduce
the guests we have here in just a moment
but before we do that i want to thank a
few important folks that
help support our series i first want to
thank the hollywood foreign press
association
they've supported film independent
presents for a long long time and a
number of
other programs as well so thank you to
them and thanks to vision media
vision media is our partner who helps
host the screenings that our members
enjoy now on a really regular basis we
have a pretty
robust event calendar these days to
check that out
definitely go to filmindependent.org
events
i'm sure many of you are very familiar
with that url
and last but not least i want to thank
the los angeles times our
media partner so with those
introductions and thank yous out of the
way
let's say hello to the filmmakers behind
the social dilemma which is on netflix
right now the director
of social the social dilemma jeff
orlowski and
we got to do like a little let's all
clap in our living rooms for jeff
and now let's do the same for the
producer of the social dilemma larissa
rhodes
welcome you guys thanks so much for
being here awesome thank you cooper
you're making me i want to bring my own
laugh track now i'm just going to bring
an applause track
a laugh track and just like queue it up
for for a virtual
you know you you signed on for this
thinking we were going to talk about
your documentary it's really
i'm going to do a lot of bits a lot of
gag perfection
on zoom protocols right right
so okay let's let's jump in and
to me in my mind this is the beginning
at least
of where this project sort of was born
and i'd love to hear
first how you two uh came together and
became collaborators
um at the outset of what eventually
became a social dilemma
totally um larissa and i actually been
working together for over a decade now
um when i was working on my first
feature chasing ice
uh we had gotten introduced to each
other through some mutual friends
uh and one of the producers on that
project and um i had some small
commercial gigs they were big at the
time i guess um they were like these big
little commercial spots that um was how
i was paying the bills at the time and
larissa came on to produce them
and uh that really just kick-started a
long working relationship now and she
came on to chasing ice and chasing coral
in the social dilemma and so it's been
this
uh creative partnership that has spanned
many many projects
yeah it's been a really fun journey to
go from making what as jeff said
they were a really big deal commercial
wise when we were first doing them
but looking at this production uh very
small in comparison so i think we've
come a long way
yeah ironically those were for an
app at the time and we learned how to
film uh like moving ipads and doing
overlays and it's like so much of the
same
practices and techniques that have been
needed in the social dilemma except from
a completely different
era and style a glimpse of the future
before you even realized it
we were just practicing we knew it was
coming i love it i love it and
one thing i forgot to mention i do want
to let the folks who are watching know
if anyone out there has questions uh
just look at the bottom of your zoom
screen there and click on that q
a button um we'll be having uh this
ongoing chat for a little while and then
certainly would love to
ask any questions that you have for of
uh jeff and larissa
so feel free to share those um
now let's get into the scary stuff
because you certainly
scared the you-know-what out of me i've
been a couple of times
but let me share an anecdote that my
sister told me about my sister phoebe
up in seattle has deleted facebook the
app from her phone
so at the beck and call of some of your
subjects she
listened and and uh took action
and interestingly the reason why i bring
this up once the app was gone
she started receiving text messages from
facebook asking her to come back
yes so let me put this to you
well yeah there have been things like
that that you've heard from
people on the crew your family yourself
okay so
what uh what your sister experienced is
called the resurrection algorithm which
is a very intentional and
literally programmed thing where if you
are a user that then stops using
they consider you dead to them and they
need to resurrect you back to the
platform
it was this experience for me that
having learned about this
and then um after stopping to use social
media
um so two years ago in the middle of
production i stopped all social media
usage and i saw
the resurrection algorithm in effect
emails text messages
consistent text messages different names
different people
here's a photo that somebody posted
here's a you know uh
blah blah blah like all of the stuff so
there's a whole i've got a collection i
renamed the phone number facebook
resurrection so that was a
particular one that i was getting at the
time and um and
every time i would just get these pings
on a regular basis while making the
movie so
um what your what your sister
experienced is nothing
out of the ordinary it is uh very very
intentional very designed
and for me it was part of the reflection
that
these platforms don't have our best
interests at heart
right it's not designed to make you uh
feel more fulfilled in life it was
really just to get you to come back to
the platform
to see more ads so they make more money
um and that that was really uh
not an uncommon thing that your sister
is experiencing
that's it's fascinating and it actually
reminds me i believe now tell me if i'm
wrong is that is right the word
resurrection used in the film by vincent
yes yeah so we we planted that uh it's
awesome that you picked up on that
because i was
we actually had so many times in the
movie
literally a facebook employee explaining
that yeah we call them resurrections and
yeah that's what we do
and it just sort of detracted a little
bit didn't really seem to click so
um we left this little easter egg around
using that specific word in the movie
without hitting the whole point
but that that's why it's in there
because this is actually what they
call it internally at the companies and
they they've even hacked the psychology
so they they've tried to figure out okay
well
if a text message or an email won't get
you to come back they're gonna put up
five
pictures of your friends and that say oh
jeff is gonna miss you if you leave and
now i'm drawn
into so it really is at such a deep
level trying to figure out what works on
you to get you to say well i actually
don't i don't want jeff to feel bad that
i'm leaving the platform
um when in fact jeff doesn't care or
doesn't know that i'm trying to leave
the platform
wow yeah it's you know i found it
so harrowing i think is the right word
to know
that and you know and and we'll get into
this in a moment you have
so many let's just call them what they
are just
genius subjects who are at the top of
their field
and luckily are thinking about ethical
matters which is not
can't be said for everyone in the tech
world but let me
listen let me ask you first specifically
you know we just mentioned
vincent um and you have a really great
group
of actors in this film
did you know at the outset when you're
coming on its producer hey not only am i
going to be producing a documentary but
i'm going to be weaving in some
narrative elements too or did jeff
spring that on you
how do those kind of creative elements
come together it was certainly a
challenging production uh interweaving
them and i think
jeff from the very beginning recognized
that this was an issue
that is is very much invisible um it is
things that are happening on the other
side of your phone
and and so trying to figure out well how
do we visualize it beyond just
interviews and so in addition to trying
to make the interviews
you know more kinetic um being able to
have multiple angles
through i think he always had a vision
of we need something else
but it definitely didn't start with a
narrative script i think the original
idea was
much more looking at something like the
big shorts and thinking how could we do
that in the reverse because
they're able to talk about subprime
mortgages and get people to care and
laugh
and i thought well how do we do that
with algorithms and
i think it was it was very much trying
to figure that out through the process
but it was
i think about a year jeff before we
actually had a script or an idea
of actually making it a narrative
through line as opposed to just sort of
interstitials
yeah i was going to say i feel like we
all
were all surprised by the process like
even when i was like
damn we have to do this idea i remember
there was there was a moment
when i was sitting on a plane to go meet
up with some of our
subjects and the idea really started
crystallizing
because as larissa said we had this
notion of vignettes and like how could
we do it and we were really trying to
experiment with that and then
then the idea sort of crystallized that
this could all be one continuous
narrative story that accomplishes all
these different things it accomplishes
the
um kind of the anthropomorphizing of the
algorithm it accomplishes
seeing it in people in real life it
gives you something to latch on to
um hopefully maybe for the for the
non-documentary audience it might
resonate in a different way
because maybe the average person that
that's on social media isn't you
isn't used to watching documentaries of
um a lot of information so
we were thinking through what are the
creative ways and uh when all of these
sort of ideas gelled into one then we
were at a point where it's like well we
need to do this like i i can't picture
making the film any other way now
um and all of these challenges are going
to be real but um
we we felt like we were up to the
challenge and the fun of it
and the amazing team and cast like you
said cooper really
such a herculean effort yeah um
i mean to pull that off to be able to
weave those things together
and again with with a traditional or
more traditional documentary element too
of some animation
sequences that help tell the story in a
visual way
um i think you guys found a really good
sweet spot in
the amount of time devoted to each of
those pieces and traditional interviews
as filmmakers now we talked about this
right before we started this
little broadcast we were talking about
your your backgrounds
you know as filmmakers documentarians
you know okay hey we're going to need
some
specific visuals that are going to help
us tell our story and
and get our message across just tell me
a little bit about
like larissa we said about your
background you have this specific
brand new emoted emoji set that's built
out by
graphic designers and a team tell me
about this piece of it because i don't
think it's talked about enough
and it's such a huge part of what
documentaries are and can be
i mean it was really exciting for us to
try to think through
how we would weave these stories
together and i think
we had an opportunity to try to use
every sort of creative juice that was
uh available from everything from the
vfx which the vfx team i have to give
them huge props they did
such an incredible job they were able to
create like you said not only their own
kind of graphic emojis because it was
cheaper for us to do that than to try to
license other ones to be honest but
uh in that creativity i think it
unleashed just an entire world that we
got to build
i think that was the first time we were
trying to envision what what
happens on the other side of your phone
and how does it try to hook you when
orchestrated and how is it puppeteering
you
um from the moment you wake up to all
the way through your bathroom call to
you know whatever else happens through
your day and i think um it was
it was just really kind of a fun process
and also i think extremely challenging
and
the team had just an unreal timeline
because this issue
is was so current everything was
unfolding as we were filming
um wanting to try to keep the the eye on
the meta story there were news stories
constantly breaking about what was
happening at each one of these companies
um but really trying to think through
what is the big picture what is the meta
story
um and how do we make sure that we're
able to communicate that a
way that it's not only you know
interesting but hopefully
that it gets people to walk away with a
new perspective on their technology
right um you're
one of your primary subjects tristan
right uh harris i believe is that
yeah yeah he i had
trouble as i was preparing to to meet
and chat with you guys about this
he makes so many revelatory statements
in such a simple way
that's so easily digestible um
and one of the one of the ones that has
stood out to me is his bicycle analogy
yes he talked about a bicycle nobody
started freaking out in the world when
we had
you know bikes to get around town and
because it's a tool it's a tool right as
opposed to
what a lot of things on here have become
you know is instagram a tool is twitter
a tool
is facebook a tool i mean i love that
he's raising that question and certainly
his opinion and i believe your opinion
as filmmakers is is made clear in the
film
tell me about how your personal opinions
change even just during the making of
the film because i'm sure
these insights from your subjects must
have been
revelatory not just to us as an audience
but to you too as filmmakers right
i mean i think that was one of the one
of the biggest challenges for us
is that we were sitting on so many
brilliant ideas throughout the entire
making of the movie
um powerful analogies and and uh
it was really some of the earliest cuts
was just like you know three hours of
brilliant ideas and it becomes
overwhelming when you can't even like
almost too many analogies and now it
sticks but the the bicycle one that you
reference
um is one that i always really really
resonated with and we wanted to make it
a theme
throughout the film um even though to be
fully fully frank there's like a slight
technical inaccuracy like some people
did apparently have objection
but the point that tristan's making
there really um what he's what he's
drilling like
it didn't disrupt society it didn't
disrupt like democracy
um and the the reason why we felt good
keeping it it goes
full swing to the very very end of the
film with um
[Music]
steve jobs referencing a computer as a
bicycle for the mind
and this was always the thing that
seemed so um
powerful in my mind around what is a
computer doing it is
allowing you just like a bicycle to go
farther to go faster to
to have more capacity um and to
accomplish more
uh i think i look back at the era of
steve jobs around
what the apple computer and then adobe
and
you know final cut and all these
creative tools like that was always for
me the most exciting
era of these wow you can use photoshop
in this way
and look at the visuals that you can
make um
and so that that was an analogy that
just really absolutely stuck
in in the uh in the film for all of us i
think
really showcasing what could be a
creative tool
like zoom this is a great technology
platform that we're using as a tool
right and allows us to have this
conversation across different states at
the same
time and share it with others like that
is a brilliant use
of technology as a tool and i think
that's one of the big things that i just
want to
add in here like this is not a film
that's anti-technology like i'm
i personally am super pro technology i
think many of the people on our team we
love technology we love great technology
we just want the technology to be
designed for the public
for society for society's interests not
to be some manipulative
money sucking system that exists on top
of all humanity
that's sort of trading in in our human
experience as the currency
right this is um what these platforms
have become unfortunately
where we are as shashana zubov says um
we're the raw resource being extracted
by this system of surveillance
capitalism um
so that i'm so thrilled that you you uh
resonated with that because that was
such a big concept for me and i think
changed the way larissa and i
work with each other think about the
software that we use how we relate how
we
talk with our whole team when is it
serving us as a tool versus when is it
trying to get something out of us
yeah i you know i'm thinking about
as the way you know as you just
described these companies jeff
there's so much money and power that
they hold
let let me ask you did you now certainly
the the subjects that we see sharing
their experiences and thoughts and
beliefs on screen
we're willing to do that so this is a
two-part question
the first part did it take
for any of them or maybe across the
board any convincing was there
apprehension
oh i'm sorry jeff what was that no i was
just wasn't sure if larissa wanted to
chime in or i can answer that easily
larissa go ahead jump
our question we'll answer the first part
and then you can go to this video go for
it
yeah i mean it was certainly a process
trying to figure out how to get some of
these individuals on camera some of them
wanted to talk to their lawyers i think
you know there's a lot of um power
in what a lot of them had to say and
their experiences i think really
resonated with people because it was
the fact that they were helping build
this technology they were there at the
ground floor in some cases
um choosing what the business model
would look like and how
you know us as the users would be
treated and i think
uh it is brave of many of them to be
able to speak out and at the same
time i think they felt a lot of
responsibility in some cases and wanted
to share their story because
it is important that we understand how
these technologies work and it is
important to think through
who gets to choose and who's part of
those ground floor decisions and
um i i think for us it was no question
to try to figure out how do we ensure
that
as we tell the story we're doing justice
to the individuals in the story but more
importantly
i think to the actual issue at stake and
and how each of us as individuals are
being you know manipulated by
by these technologies and for what
purpose and to what end
yeah um that
there's a poignancy in that you know
it's where we have to kind of all
almost generally excuse me
generationally think about you know
hey listen okay i'm of a certain age
where i remember i'm nearing the end of
college and
facebook is starting to make its
appearance and
begin its dominance right and you know
i'm actually looking at
a question from one of our our viewers
that makes me think about younger
generations which you
touch on in a really
pointed way to make a message clear
about what's happening especially with
young women
young girls and josh is asking you know
he says as a parent of a teen
i found the film so illuminating and
important while i'd love for our family
to get off social media or dramatically
rethink how we use it
you know there's an isolation that we're
all experiencing right now
in america and throughout the world
because of our global pandemic
and it seems that that has made these
online platforms more desirable and
especially anything
to his child and to him he says in to me
too if i'm being honest
so do you have any thoughts about how
the pandemic
is impacting not only how we use it now
but potentially long term
oh so many thoughts on that um an
analogy that just came to my mind that i
don't think i've actually ever used
before
is that social media is almost like the
fast food version of a relationship
it's like the cheap unhealthy version
one of our subjects um
referenced it as it doesn't actually
offer connection it's connectivity
but not connection and so if you're
sitting home and you're alone
and you're lonely and you're like oh let
me go check and i'll swipe and it's it
stimulates
the brain in a lot of different ways and
it works differently for you than it
does for me
in a different feed and different
content and some people want to be on
youtube for hours other people want to
look at instagram for hours
um but these platforms collectively have
all reverse engineered all of us
and figured out what's the thing that
cooper's most vulnerable to
and it knows what information what
balance of news or friends and family or
visuals or headlines or you know tweets
or what aspect of what political debate
cooper's interested in and it'll give
you that particular fee that's going to
get you to come back
and so it really is just like the french
fries of the food diet
right and um and so
one of the things that i like to think
about is like if i'm feeling that
pull i'm home i'm lonely what am i
actually looking for
am i looking to get news about the world
so
instead of going to that social media
feed maybe i go to an actual news
service or pick up a book right
or am i look right i mean i've been
reading
so during this movie i started to read
books on paper more
and it was really hard actually to be
like it was really really difficult
to have the patience to sit back and
read a book
and it was like this weird exercise i
had to go through to like
remind my brain oh you can do this like
you've done this before you like you
know what
right um or are you looking you know in
those moments are you looking for
family connection friend connection why
don't you just pick up the phone
that you're holding already and just
call somebody
or do a facetime or get a different
level of connection with friends and
family and so that that's in my process
during covid
i have stopped using social media a
couple years ago i haven't gone back to
it
and i felt the desire at times during
cover like oh i wonder what's
and then just reminding myself no i can
actually just call that person
and have a meaningful conversation or
have a facetime or
zoom where once again we've paid for
these products right we've
paid for these accounts when you get
your iphone you get face time built in
when you get whatever
and and so leveraging the tools that are
available for you
for human connection as opposed to
i think as the question poses i mean
it's a real slippery slope and it's
really really easy
to fall back and to slide onto these
platforms during this moment in time
where we get this seeming sense of
connection there
i am really really concerned and fearful
however that it is
just amplifying misinformation that
we've seen over the course of this year
whether it's covid whether it's
political whether it's just the
politicizing of
masks right and so i think that's one of
the big things that we tried to talk
about in the film
is um these platforms will put
anybody into a filter bubble like we've
figured out what keeps cooper engaged
it's this particular slice of this
particular conversation
and we can just keep showing more and
more and more because that's that's how
the algorithm works
um and so in my mind
these platforms if you're getting
information if you're getting your news
which the majority of americans now get
some of their news from these platforms
every day
i think it is act actively leading to a
less informed electorate
a less informed public because you're
getting biased
personalized information on a daily
basis for
years and years now and i think like for
josh as
a parent and as a teen who has a teen i
guess i should say
i think what we learned is that um we
did a student screening actually of the
film
before the pandemic started and then we
ended up re-editing to include the
pandemic but in that student screening
we were floored by the fact that a lot
of the students were saying
i know about this issue but you've got
to tell my parents to get off of
facebook or tell my grandma to get off
of facebook like
the the kids at some point know more
than the adults and recognize that
they're being pulled they have this like
fomo is a real thing and they have this
fear of missing out
um that is controlling their social
movements and like
in some cases they would make a pact and
say as a group of
individuals our friends are all going to
get off of social media together because
we recognize that
um it's not actually as gen i've said
connecting us it is just connectivity
and we'd rather hang out
in a different way or communicate
without a third party manipulating us so
i think in some senses like the kids
might be a generation where
they understand it more so than the
adults do at this point
yeah it's it's interesting interesting
to think about it that way because i
think a lot of
times you know i think now more than
ever
not only are there is there a political
split there's a split between what
people believe is true and not
right and split between what people feel
uh what they expect from a generation
right
gen x versus you know millennials versus
gen
z and alersa it's interesting to hear
you
um put those in terms that i don't think
people often
think about right where maybe that
younger generation actually has a better
handle on things than you give them
credit for
um yeah and just to add to that many uh
some of the students they came up to us
after that screening and they were like
we get it we're living this every day
you guys don't understand what it feels
like to have to be on
your entire life like we remember an era
before social media
and we had i think if you're of a
certain age and you
you've gone through your developmental
phase of life
with just the normal stresses of middle
school right
and not these extra everything you do
is documented for posterity um your
entire social value your social
connection the
the relationships that you have is
determined by like how many people
respond to the thing that you post and
how quickly and
and to have to feel this constant
pressure to perform
on on a as a teenager like that that's a
huge
burden that's a huge emotional struggle
and and i don't envy uh josh i mean it's
like
having kids in this era is a really
really challenging thing
one of the things i would suggest or
offer is um hopefully if your kid
watches the film
but then also to to watch it together
but to have
their friends watch the movie and have
those families talk together and have a
packed within a friend circle about what
do we want our social media relationship
to look like
how do we want to engage as a family and
as a community as a pod as
as a group because if it's really hard
for one kid to get off of social
on their own because the rest of the
friend circle is still on social
right so that's a huge huge challenge
yeah you know it this actually i've been
looking at this question from one of our
viewers sarah
um and that what you just said makes me
think now is the time
she asks uh many of your interviewees
claimed not to have realized the
negative potential
of their inventions yeah you don't then
this is a question to you and then i
want to add one little thing to it she
asks do you believe them
yeah you know and then i think back like
we just said of being a certain agent of
course i'm remembering
facebook's early early moments and years
and you know we've we know the story we
know it was created by mark zuckerberg
as essentially a
literally a facebook let's compare let's
look at women
let's rate them let's hot or not.com
from the early 2000s those concepts
so that i love what sarah asked you know
do you believe the folks that you got to
be in the film
um or do you think that they knew maybe
there was something else to it yeah
it's a it's a really great question and
i i both um
extend a lot of empathy and a lot of
skepticism
based on who we're talking about when
where
what timeline i i think that there was
in many cases a genuine desire for
positive impact
and the the tools and i remember friends
who worked in the industry who were like
wow the arab spring we just were able to
like
help like a political conversation
advance because people are talking on
this platform that we helped build
and that seemed extremely exciting um
with some of our subjects jaren lanier
talked about the cycle of like
like a country gets on the internet um
democracy rises for a little bit as
people are
having more and more conversation and
then it falls as bad actors learn how to
manipulate it and the whole thing
and he like he referenced this pattern
that we see in many countries
um i think for me the part where i i
have a hard time
extending empathy around is like when
they switched over their advertising
model
to to an advertising model and they
started building out around
well this is how we're going to generate
revenue once again it seemed really
innocent at the start
but at a certain time point in time like
we became the commodity
and the objective became like extracting
monetary value from us the public and
we're now at a point where
i feel like there is no excuse like we
know what these companies are doing and
i
i place their business model on um on an
ethical level of fossil fuels
and we just like you know we've some
people found fossil fuels on the ground
a long time ago i was like this is
amazing look at what it can do
and this is awesome for society and then
years later we realized wait a second
this is having consequences and impacts
and maybe we need to do something about
it
it's it's that same level of we created
a frankenstein
but how do we shift the system now how
do we get off of an extractive
industry whether it is the fossil fuel
industry or it is
um extractive technology
yeah i oh larissa did you want to jump
out
no i don't i don't have much to add to
that i think when
you think about the subjects and where
they are in a sense of time
um i agree with with what you were even
saying too about when this technology
came out it was
really fun it was really exciting to be
able to connect with people around the
world i have friends
around the world instagram was really
cool to be able to like you know
create create photos and share artist
communities and
even like snapchat you know get the the
new technology tick tock there's
there's all of these like fun pieces to
it and easy pieces to it and i think the
the question has become what have we
lost as a result of that what kind of
relationships do we actually have now
and what kind of friends do i actually
have jeff says this a lot like
facebook co-opted the word friends i
have like 10 000 friends on facebook
but are they all really my friends how
many of them actually called me on my
birthday today because i'm not on social
media you know
i i think there's really um just a
questioning of what kind of
relationships do we want to have and is
are these social media platforms the way
we want to engage and interact
constantly
life and i think with kovid there are a
lot of people who def
like their lives rely on this technology
and these connections but
um i i do think that at this point
it feels like we need to as a community
try to figure out different ways for us
to try to connect and maintain these
relationships because
it isn't sustainable it's not just like
jeff said we're being
a raw resource extracted and just like
climate change um
it isn't something that's going to be
able to continue sustainably
yeah today's not your birthday though
right larissa
no not today okay for a brief second i
was like holy could i just forget like
no jeff is a good friend jeff williams
but hey jeff jeff is off of social media
and that's the only way you would open
someone's birthday
it's true the funny i have like my
calendar entries from friends from
before social media that are still in my
address book and everything and it's
like
those long time friends whose birthdays
i see regularly yeah
yeah yeah larissa used a great term
there a good hyphenate co-opted because
i don't think i would remember my
friends or even family members birthdays
like mom dad sister okay
immediate yeah but yeah like and i love
them so much but even my cousins aunts
uncles
we're they're on facebook i'm still on
facebook even though i don't use it a
ton
you still get that little birthday
reminder
and and it feels great it feels great
but your birthday feels great on social
media you just get all of this
um affirmation but is it real connection
yeah right yeah connection versus
connectivity which you said
yeah um let me ask you just a little uh
shifting gears i want to ask um on
behalf of alva who's
who's tuned in this is kind of about
your
timeline as filmmakers so let's back up
a little bit
um how did you make contact with the
contributors
and current slash x tech employees that
are in the film
right did any come and seek you out was
there kind of a watershed moment when
they realized some colleagues people
that
whilst they're involved or right how
would you convince them to take part
i can't think of anybody reaching out to
us in large part to be totally frank
because we were trying to keep the
production somewhat hush-hush
um we were not i mean we didn't post
about it on social media
but we weren't actively you know this
was um
we looked at this as investigative
journalism at the start and wanting to
understand something
without um kind of tipping our hand
too much uh too early so the the real
insight at the beginning was through
tristan harris um who as you mentioned
he's one of our main subjects and he
um this is where uh everything starts
off in a fully ironic place i first saw
traston speak on 60 minutes
via a post that he made on facebook and
we had known each other from college and
passing
and i knew that he worked at google we
had both worked as apple campus reps so
i knew him through that because we loved
the computers
and uh then i heard him speak as a
google employee
criticizing the techniques that google
and other companies were using
and all of my friends in college like so
many worked in tech and i'd never heard
this before
so that was really that in the first
catalyst was
wait a second so tristan i got to
understand what you're talking about
here and then i spoke to a mutual friend
that i knew worked in tech and knew
tristan will and asked
what is he talking about is there
something here and that friend was like
yeah there's
he's he's really onto something i was
skeptical at first but he's on to
something
and it was through that it was just
trying to find okay so who else is
thinking about this who else is talking
about it like this
um and so uh it was through that
initial network that we were getting
those connections i fully want to
acknowledge there are
many many people in academia in
particular that have been working and
studying
the impacts and consequences of tech for
many many years now um that's something
that we didn't know about at the time
in fact we were just getting introduced
uh to a lot of these subjects
um and over the course of 2018 when we
really started doing our interviews we
started meeting and getting connected to
more and more academics but
there's a there's a big field of people
that have been criticizing
or analyzing and critiquing and
understanding what
is technology doing to society to our
population to kids all of this
um the asymmetric impacts on
marginalized communities and how tech
impacts and affects people very
differently
um so there's a there's a really
powerful field of study that has been
looking into this um
and hopefully this the our film is just
a contribution to
the work and to the um to the thinking
and the research that's been done
and just adding more wind to those sales
yeah
oh yeah please well i was just going to
say that you know there were interviews
that we unfortunately also couldn't
include in the film we did a number of
interviews that ended up on the cutting
room floor we did
some anonymous interviews as well that
we didn't end up using so
um it was it was very much an
exploratory process for us and i think
we're still learning as
you know new details about these
platforms as we read more still better
understanding how
this technology is actually affecting
the way that we live our lives
um larissa let me stick with you here
and ask you
and then jeff certainly uh follow up do
you feel like
this film being on a platform like
netflix
do you think will this not only lead to
some education
for for the public some realizations but
do you think that this will
potentially drive filmmakers to continue
to explore
maybe even new ground beyond some of the
areas where you have
have taken steps and and gotten
information and and
do you think this will be a catalyst to
something else absolutely i mean
i think we feel so lucky to have had the
distribution
that we had with netflix it allowed us
to be in multiple countries around the
world
um just millions of people having access
to the story is huge
as a docu independent documentary
filmmaker it is
just an incredible experience to have
that many people
be able to watch your film um so i think
for us it was
just amazing uh and at the same time i
think
uh it also allowed for us to have a
shared conversation and i think tristan
talks about this a lot in the film
that we've reached a point in our
ecosystem of information
that we literally are seeing two
different worlds and and
each one of us living in our own truman
show our own filter bubbles
have kind of broken down the fact that
we don't have a shared truth and i think
the hope is
with this film and many of the other
films as jeff was saying that have come
out
around these issues and will probably
continue to come out around these issues
are allowing us to have a shared
conversation about at least something
that we know is true and is happening
and then from there maybe we can kind of
wake up a little bit from the matrix
and be able to try to figure out how do
we want this technology to work for us
as opposed to manipulating us um and and
i think as jeff was saying there there
are so many other
you know films and topics that are
similar um but slightly different uh
to the thesis of this film and it
reminds me a lot again of climate change
it's something that jeff and i
spent almost 10 years of our life
working in and and with climate change
there's so many issues there's
ocean acidification and agricultural
runoff and you know
uh plastic pollution in the ocean and it
was trying to figure out how do you tell
the story of climate change and it's
like we need
all of the stories we need so many more
stories until people wake up to that
issue and i think this is
a very similar issue it is an
existential level crisis that undermines
any issue that we are about
uh i completely agree with everything
you just said there larissa i mean this
is just
um as larissa said our past films were
climate-related chasing ice and chasing
coral
and uh because those films exist um
is no reason why a gazillion other great
climate movies
shouldn't exist right there's so many
different stories to tell
about how our climate's changing um this
is
uh in my mind i feel like there are a
couple of films that have come out
already on
tech and they're more coming out this
year there's a great film called coded
bias
that just like started in theaters a
week ago a thousand cuts is out this
year the cleaners the great hack there's
there's a small collection of films that
have really been at this leading edge of
um like this new um perspective and
critique of tech
and i think it's only going to grow and
grow and grow in the years to come
and i think the thing to think about
there is um
technology we used to think of the tech
industry
as a handful of companies in silicon
valley that made chips and made hardware
and there was just like a very
limited scope of the tech industry um
now you look at the biggest companies
apple and google and they're all doing
these are all separate monopolies
in separate industries with separate
business models like
they in some ways they might compete
with each other but in reality they're
in their own little silo and
we now live in an era where it's not a
tech industry
all industries use technology all
industries are using algorithms
wall street is using algorithms all the
time to do trading
prison sentencing recommendations for
are coming via algorithms who you know
who is the college going to pick for
the next class of freshmen that's being
filtered through algorithms
technology is in our entire society now
and we have
no access or transparency into
wait a second how is that algorithm
operating that's choosing those college
students
and is there bias is there racism
that we know that to be the case that
there are many examples of algorithms
that have
racist data that has fed into them so if
you are working with
um with historical data that might have
a bias in it
how do we overcome the challenges we're
hoping to overcome
if the algorithm is literally just
giving us more of the same
right and so we we're now in an era
where
algorithms have gotten so powerful and
they affect so many aspects of our daily
lives
and yet we have no oversight no
transparency and no
no real understanding of what it's doing
to each and every one of us
that's a very new point in human history
yeah it's you that that alone
i mean just like you were saying about
about the climate this
massive thing that has so many granular
pieces any one of which could be
explored
in immense depth that's certainly the
case with what
you look at in the social dilemma and
just algorithms we could talk about just
algorithms from another
just yeah what how much time do we have
exactly exactly
you know machine learning it's such a
crazy concept
machine learning these a computer can
teach
itself how to get better over time right
that is completely new that is not just
like writing a code to accomplish you
know to play chess it's writing the code
so that it teaches itself
how to play chess and now that you can't
ever beat the code anymore because it's
just
so much better than any one of us yeah
and it's all fun and games when it's
like
chess or go or you know one of the
things but then when it becomes
your job or your mortgage or the next
oppenheimer esque project
you know whose hands are we putting all
of that power into and who gets to
choose
yeah um before we run out of time i do
want to ask
one more question from one of our
viewers carlos and um
i think about his question in the terms
of what we were just talking about
and how okay we talked about the
subjects that are on screen
the the visual effects that are used to
help the you know the animation that's
used
to drive these points home one thing we
haven't talked about that he
is asking about is the music in the film
yeah um that he feels is very effective
and i certainly agree
and he's asking what direction if any
did you give
the composers or musicians to get the
right balance
of what he felt and i think we all felt
is he
uses the words engagement versus dread
right
that's a good framework um our composer
mark crawford just did a brilliant job
with the film
um and we've worked together on a number
of projects and um
our editor davis uh was you know at the
start of an edit
you take a bunch of different music in
from different sources and different
inspiration and what composers have done
things that sound similar and davis was
just collecting all the stuff and
putting it into
some of the early scenes and i'd sit
there and and be in the edit room and
listen like wait a second who
where did that song come from oh mark
wrote it oh interesting and then like
another time
where did this song come from oh mark
wrote that one too and mark was just
supplying davis with like
ideas and thoughts and just sketches um
and davis was able to work them in in a
really really powerful way and it just
became clear
that he he got the vibe and the tone for
this film
um so we went through and we were
spotting it i felt like mark had such a
natural instinct
for what is that balance um we went for
this balance between
analog and digital at different times in
different scenes throughout the film and
this kind of shift between like
the more human worlds with analog
instrumentation versus more
synthesized and digital to kind of
provide the subconscious effect
and it was just uh it was just a great
process i think mark had this intuition
as well
around how we wanted to look at the
whole structure of the film and when we
build towards the climax but also
give relief at the end and inspiration
and hope um and
mapping out that emotional journey
through the music like
starting ominous was kind of the frame
at different times and
how do we elevate the stakes and get
people to really feel
the the severity and the weight of what
we're talking about um
and and be able to navigate throughout
the the course of the film
yeah it was beautifully effective and i
love that
i i did pick up on those moments where i
mean listen as an 80s kid
as a fan of 80s music i love that you
use those
machine moments where you're using tones
made by machines
right at home right message you know
yeah it was really
really powerful i thought yeah he had a
lot of fun too because i think he
he was also part of the sound production
so he was listening to some of the
interviews and had a sense of what the
story
was listening to all the subjects kind
of speak um
and being able to kind of from the
inception working with jeff to think
through what would that transition from
a human world to a digital world look
like so i think there were analog
synths in there and all sorts of things
that you would love
uh yeah it it oh the first thing that
came to my mind is a terrible pun i was
literally gonna say it struck a chord
with me so there you go
nice yeah well done well done
i'm fully in dad joke mode i'm a fan
um just a minute ago i was i was gifted
a beautiful
final what will be unfortunately the
final question i mean i'm
this is so fascinating i wish we could
continue this for hours on end
um clear your schedules uh which we
don't know anymore because we're off
social media and who knows what anything
is right
um jenna who's been watching is asking
and i think jeff you may have hinted at
this a moment ago so i'll be curious to
hear you
uh build on this she's asking did you
end the production of the film with an
opinion
or feeling about how the future will
play out for us as
consumers and we of course hear the
potential of a civil war mentioned which
is
so dark yeah also unfortunately based on
what we've been seeing
not outside of the realm of possibility
but then also there is there is hope
and i love that what we see during the
credits is hey these are
very intelligent human beings who have
experience in tech
who are saying we can take small
actionable steps
to make a difference in our day-to-day
life hey just leave the phone outside of
the bedroom
etc etc so that's a big jump between
potential civil war and
hey let's take some action on our phones
to stay away from that extreme
so what are your thoughts what are your
feelings about where we're headed in the
future
um i i i like to say that i'm
optimistic because of my pessimism
and that we i feel like things are going
to get worse before they get better but
that things will get better
um i believe that both for climate and
for tech in that these systems in play
right now
are inherently unsustainable like they
we know that they can't
last but that they're also going to
yield
massive human pain and suffering and i
think it's just a matter of
how long does it take for a society to
wake up fully and say
no we don't want this anymore no we want
to
act in in better alignment with the
values of a
healthy functioning society with the
idea of a long timeline in mind
and not just act on short-term
profit-driven incentives
i i do think that our current
state of social media and how social
media and search
are putting us into filters are giving
us different information
um is a real real scary reality
um and i think that's all the more
reason why larissa and myself and our
team are so committed to continuing to
have this conversation and talk about it
because
we need to wake up from the like
alternate reality that we've been living
in on these platforms
one of the things i suggest to people is
to do a reality swap
like if there's that family member or
that friend or that person that you
disagree with politics about
show them your feed and look at their
feed and have a conversation around how
you're living in literally different
like digital worlds with different
information being fed to you all the
time
let that be a point of shared
conversation and shared truth
about the breakdown of our shared truth
um and i think we need to
to overcome that first step before we
get to the stage of okay so what does
meaningful legislation look like
how do we get the system back in in
shape how do we
repair our information ecosystem so that
we get
trustworthy reliable information that we
can use to make informed decisions
um i i believe that we will get there
um it's just a matter of when and and
the process to do that
i agree with jeff i i think
in the film one of the subjects talks
about the fact that the true optimists
are actually the pessimists because
they believe the world can be better and
i think that optimism has
inspired our team to try to figure out
what what can we do and i think it's
really easy
with a climate change or any other
existential crisis like this one
to be able to feel really hopeless and
helpless and say well i'm just one
person what can i do
um but i think this is in the film and
and
even the scientists from our previous
films have shown us that you know these
are technologies that
that we created we humans kind of got
ourselves into this mess which means
that we have a responsibility to get
ourselves out of it and
there's a lot of power in an individual
but um one of the subjects at the end of
the film justin rosenstein says
what it's going to take is collective
will we're not going to be able to fix
this problem as as you said one person
logging off of social media
when all of the friends are still on
social media we really need
collectivity to be able to say as a
nation as a
as a community as a world what kind of
technology are we going to
accept um and what kind of technology
we're going to say look that's not built
for us and i'm not going to use it and
whether that's voting with your clicks
or
choosing what social media platforms you
agree with or deciding your own kind of
usage i think
there is kind of at every level we need
to do our own individual thing and then
we need to use our voices collectively
to ask for change whether that's through
regulation or through the companies and
their design
yeah but i think we're gonna get there i
i
hope so i know all of us fingers crossed
um this has just been so enlightening i
mean certainly
talking to you but the film itself um
as our producer rachel mentioned before
we before we started today
um this conversation will live on so
hopefully
for anyone watching right now if for
some reason you haven't seen
the social dilemma yet it's on netflix
it's available right now um
and don't dm a friend about it don't
tweet a friend about it actually call
your friends
call your family please sign up have a
real connection and tell them about the
social dilemma yes
um you you guys really created a
fantastic film and i think a really
important one
um so on behalf of film independent
thank you for taking the time
because having conversations adds so
much to what you already have done
so thank you thank you so much thank you
for for having us
yes thank you so much